bien monsieur le le commissaire européen
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
chers collègues je rappelle que cette
séance est ouverte à à tous les
sénateurs chers collègues nous sommes
très heureux de de vous recevoir
aujourd'hui Monsieur le Commissaire
européen au Palais du Luxembourg et je
vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on reçoit un commissaire européen
surtout des visus parce qu'on a été
habitué longtemps à la visio et et que
certains en ont pris l'habit mais merci
d'être d'être venu ici votre audition
intervient un point nommé au lendemain
de la publication du dernier paquet
élargissement de la Commission
européenne c'est-à-dire des rapports de
progrès sur chacun des pays candidats ou
candidats potentiel à l'adhésion de
l'Union européenne après la décision
historique de reconnaître le statut de
pays candidat à l'Ukraine et à la
Moldavie prise par le
Conseil européen en juin 2022 la
Commission européenne vient hier de
recommander d'ouvrir les négociations
d'adhésion avec ces deux pays et de
reconnaître la Géorgie de reconnaître à
la Géorgie le statut de pays candidat si
la décision finale appartient au chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement qui auront à
se prononcer lors du Conseil européen
des 14 et 15 décembre prochain il s'agit
là d'une nouvelle étape essentielle et
d'un changement géopolitique majeur pour
le projet européen qui est la
conséquence directe de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie il y a presque 2
ans l'Ukraine se défend depuis avec
courage et défend en même temps nos
valeurs communes la démocratie et les
droits de l'homme lu reconnaître le
statut de pays candidat ainsi qu'à la
Moldavie et maintenant à la Géorgie
constitue un signal fort de soutien et
de solidarité de la part de l'Union
européenne en réponse aux aspirations
profondes de ces pays comme le dit le
disait Robert Schuman nous devons faire
l'Europe non seulement dans l'intérêt
des peuples libres mais aussi pour
pouvoir y accueillir les peuples de
l'Est qui délivré des suggestions qu'ils
ont subi jusqu'à présent nous
demanderaiit leur adhésion et notre
appui moral pour autant quelle
appréciation portez-vous sur l'état réel
de préparation de ces trois pays dans
quelle mesure respecte-t-il les critères
de copenhag en particulier en matre en
matière de démocratie d'État de droit de
lutte contre la corruption ou encore en
matière économique ou de capacité
administrative surtout l'Union
européenne qui s'est construite sur les
décombres de la guerre pour construire
une paix durable ne risque-t-elle pas
d'importer la guerre en son sein non
seulement celle qui sévit en Ukraine
mais aussi celle qui couvent en
Transnistrie en Abkazie ou en osétie du
Sud n'oublions pas qu'en complément des
critères de copenhag qui sont à remplir
par les candidats les pays candidats à
l'adhésion nous devons aussi considérer
la capacité de l'Union européenne à
absorber de nouveaux membres capacité
qui a été reconnue comme un critère à
part entière qui celui-ci est à remplir
par l'Union considérez-vous que l'Union
européenne est prête à accueillir de
nouveaux États membres jugez-vous que
les institutions européennes actuelles
peuvent fonctionner à 30 ou 35 pays et
si rien n'évolue quelles seraient selon
vous les conséquences de l'élargissement
sur le budget européen et les politiques
communes comme la politique agricole
commune ou la politique de
cohésion récemment la presse se faisait
l'écho d'une estimation
du conseil sur l'impact potentiel de
l'adhésion de neuf nouveaux pays dont
l'Ukraine poids lourd notamment en
termees démographique et économique
l'impact dont leur adhésion sur le
budget européen et les politiques
communes selon cette projection un tel
élargissement pourrait entraîner une
diminution de 20 % des crédits de la PAC
la fin des financements accordés au
titre de la cohésion à plusieurs états-
membres et une augmentation
significative des contributions
budgétaires nettes de certains
États-membres au premier rang desquels
la
France concernant les pays des Balcans
occidentaux leurs perspectives
européennes a été reconnu depuis plus de
20 ans leur progrès vers l'indhésion
sembleent lent et les tensions
régionales persistantes notamment entre
le Kosovo et la Serbie dans un contexte
d'influence croissante de puissances
étrangères comme la Chine la Russie ou
la Turquie comment éviter le sentiment
de lassitude des populations en
particulier de la jeunesse qui préfèrent
finir plutôt que vieillir en attendant
qui préfèrent fuir pardon plutôt que
vieillir en attendant une hypothétique
entrée de leur pays dans l'Union
européenne à vos yeux la nouvelle
méthodologie de l'élargissement adoptée
à l'initiative de la France en 2020
a-t-elle permis de renforcer le
processus avec un examen plus dynamique
des critères de copenhag et de soutenir
efficacement la transformation des
Balcans
occidentaux est-ce qu'on peut parler
réellement d'un processus plus politique
et que pensez-vous du principe de
réversibilité la formule alambiquéire
retenue hier par la commission pour
annoncer l'ouverture des négociations
avec la
Bosnie-Herzégovine sous réserve que
celle-ci remplisse certaines conditions
révèle sans doute la difficulté dans
laquelle nous demeurons pour maintenir
l'élan réformateur de ces pays sans pour
autant transiger sur les fondamentaux
qui conditionnent qui conditionnent
l'appartenance à l'Union finalement
cette formule cibiline ne dit-elle pas
la nécessité de considérer l'adhésion à
l'Union pour la rendre graduelle et
permettre ainsi aux États candidats de
récolter au fur et à mesure des fruits
de leurs efforts de réforme en entrant
successivement dans les pièces composant
l'édifice européens c'est-à-dire en
étant admis progressivement à rejoindre
une à une les politiques de l'Union
enfin n'oublions pas d'évoquer le cas de
la Turquie dont les négociations
d'adhésions sont bloqué depuis plusieurs
années qui semblent s'éloigner de plus
en plus des valeurs européennes et
prendre un autre chemin que celui qui
mène à l'adhésion comment voyez-vous
l'avenir de la trajectoire turque et je
ne reprendrai pas les les les propos
exact de Monsieur Erdogan la semaine
dernière qui fustigait l'Union
européenne de façon quasi
guerrière je vous laisse la parole
Monsieur le Commissaire européen avant
que nous poursuivions notre dialogue en
vous posant quelques questions et
j'ouvrirai la parole à la salle c'est à
vous merci monsieur
Président chers sénateurs je suis
toujours ravi de vous visiter ici à
Paris parce que je suis convaincu que la
démocratie européen commence et reste
toujours avec les parlements nationaux
donc pour moi c'est toujours une visite
très très
importante aussi pour le
voir comment notre politique est reçue
et comment é vu par les parlements
nationaux parce que vous êtes le plus
proche de des citoyens européens donc
pour moi c'est une grande occasion et
comme vous avez expliqué monsieur le
Président c'était que hier que nous
avons adopté notre paquet donc à mon
avis c'est un affaire courant euh très
très courant euh qu'on peut déjà
commencer discuter avec avec vous
aujourd'hui si vous me permettez j'ai un
petit discours à à vous partager après
je suis prêt euh de de répondre tous les
questions vous avez posé quand même une
liste importante mais après on peut on
peut peut-être s'engager à à répondre
donc euh cette année nous présentons une
vaste train de mesures sur
l'élargissement avec des rapports euh
pour la première fois couvrant 10 pays
euh
incluant maintenant Ukraine Moldavie et
la Georgie et le plan de croissance pour
le Balcans occidentaux
euh donc la Commission a recommandé
comme vous avez aussi évoqué au Conseil
d'ouvrir des négociations d'adhésion
avec Ukraine et
Moldavie nous avons recommandé également
d'ouvrir les négociation d'adhésion avec
la Bosnie une fois que le degré
nécessaire de conformité avec les
critères d'adhésion sera atteint en
outre nous recommandons d'accorder le
statut des pays candidat à la Georgie
attend entendu que certaines mesures
sont prises en ce qui concerne l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie nous recommandons
également au conseil adopter le cadre de
négociation une fois que l'Ukraine et
Moldavie auront progressé sur les lois
relatives euh à la lutte contre la
corruption la vérification des avoirs et
pris des nouvelles mesures en matière de
des oligaras des
oligarcasisation j'ai jamais utilisé ce
mot en français euh les deux pays
devront continuer à lutter contre la
corruption en obtenant des résultats
supplémentaires en matière d'enquête et
des condamnations en matière de
corruption en ce qui concerne les
minorités nationales euh Ukraine doit
reprendre aux recommandations en en
insistance de la Commission de Venise de
juin et de l'octobre de cette année-ci
lié à la Loi sur les minorité nationale
l'Ukraine doit également donner suite la
recommandation de la Commission de
Venise relative aux lois sur les langues
d'État et les médias et
l'éducation dans le cas de l'Ukraine et
de la Moldavie la commission suivra de
manière continue les progrès et la
conformité dans tous les domaines liés à
l'ouverture des négociations et fera
rapport au Conseil d'ici mars de l'année
prochaine la Commission est prête à
étamer les travaux préparatoires en
particulier le rblage de l'acquis donc
le
screening et la préparation du cadre de
négociation
en Georgie nous avons assisté à une
nouvelle dynamique positive de dialogue
avec nous au cours de derniers mois en
particulier en ce qui concerne la les 12
priorités par conséquence la commission
recommande au Conseil d'accorder à la
Georgie le statut de pays candidat àant
entendu que des nouvelles mesures sont
prises en ce qui concerne la lutte
contre
désinformation la
l'animement sur le
pesque l'améoration de la mise en œuvre
du contrôle parlementaire et la
résolution du problème de polarisation
politique et de encore une fois la
question des doligergation et la lutte
contre la corruption en ce qui concerne
euh la
bosnieherzégovine l'année dernière le
statut de candidat a apporté une
dynamisme indispensable et de jamais vu
un nouveau gouvernement a rapidement été
mis en place après les les élections et
a commencé à mettre en œuvre les
réformes à tout niveau de
pays l'engagement public des partis
politiques en faveur de l'objectif
stratégique de l'intégration européen a
donné a donné des résultats
positifs le Conseil des ministres a
approuvé ensemble des projets de loi
notamment sur inité du système
judiciaire la prévention de torture par
désignation de médiator comme mécanisme
national de prévention euh loi des
étrangères et la liberté d'accès à
information elles ont tous adopté par le
Parlement
déjà le point de contact pour Europol a
commencé à fonctionner ce qui était un
progrès très très attendu des progrès
modestes ont été accomplis en ce qui
concerne l'alignement sur la pesque et
la
bosnieherzégovine a considérablement
amélioré son alignement sur la politique
étrangère de l'Union
européenne je pourrais continuer avec
une longue liste évolution positive au
cours de l'année qui est écoulé
importantes stratégies ont été adoptées
en matière de lutte contre le
blanchiment de capitaux de même que des
plans d'action en matière de migration
de TER terrorisme ou la mise en œuvre de
stratégie nationale de traitement des
crimes de
guerre le budget de l'État pour cette
année-ci a été adopté en mars la base
juridique pour la conduite de
négociation sur les les interconnexions
gazières du Sud et de l'Est a été adopté
l'accord de coopération avec Eurojust a
été également adopté et deux autres
accords de mobilité régionale euh dans
dans la procédure de Berlin ont été
ratifié la commission encourage les
dirigeants politiques et tous les
autorités à poursuivre ce bilan positif
et redoubler des efforts pour répondre à
toutes les priorité essentiell qui
subsistant euh la Commission recommande
l'ouverture de négociation d'adhésion
avec la
bosniehzégovina dès que les dé
nécessaires de conirité à avec les
critères d'adhésion sera
atteint donc nous rendrons compte du
Conseil des progrès accomplis d'ici mars
de l'année
prochaine avant de me tourner vers
l'Albanie permettez-moi de dire quelques
mots sur le procédure de criblage avec
les deux pays Albanie et la N et la
macédone du Nord le processus progressè
sans sans heur et les autorités ont fait
preuve d'une niveau élevé d'engagement
et notre objectif est d'ouvrir le
premier pôle sur les fondamentaux à
d'ici fin de l'année avec
Albanie en Albanie la mise en œuvre de
la réforme globale de la justice se
poursuivre et les procédures de
vérification progressent à un rythme
satisfaisant la structure spéciale
contre la corruption et la criminalité
organisée
euh qui s'appelle SPAC a obtenu de
nouveaux résultats concrets l'alignement
complet sur la politique étrangère et de
sécurité commune a été un signal fort de
choix stratégique du pays d'adhérer à
l'Union européenne les efforts
supplémentaires sont nécessaires dans
des domaines clés de l'État de droit en
ce qui enensi queur sur la
libertéexpression les questions
relatives aux minorités et le droit de
propriété au Macédoine de Nord les
autorités ont continué de démontrer et
de décaler déclarer politiquement leur
engagement à progresser sur le voie de
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne
maintenant que les procédus processus de
négociation d'adhésion a commencé le
rythme de réformes lié à l'Union
européenne doit scaler s'accélérer
pardon euh certaines modifications
apporté au au code pénal qui concerne un
grand nombre des affaires de corruption
à haut niveau ont suscité des
inquiétudes il est essentiel de
renforcer le confi la confiance dans la
dans le système judiciaire et de lutter
contre la corruption notamment grâce à
des résultats solides en matière
d'enquête des poursuites et de
condamnation définitives dans les
affaires de corruption de haut niveau
le Parlement et le gouvernement se sont
engagés à démarrer et réaliser en
priorité les modifications
constitutionnelles pertinentes j'espère
que tous les partis soutiendront cette
proposition pour aller de l'avant il
s'agit d'une décision souveraine de la
macédone noire et un engagement qui
renforcera encore les droits
fondamentaux concernant le montenéro
si les progrès en matière de réforme
d'adhésion l'Union Européen sont en
garde parti au point de mort le
gouvernement nouvellement nommé doit
désormais se concentrer sur les réformes
liées à l'Union européenne et veiller à
ce que les institutions démocratiques et
le pouvoir judiciaire du pays deviennant
un fois de plus pleinment
opérationnel respect des critères des
critères provisoires fixés dans le
chapitre
2324 relatif à l'état de droit sera
essentiel pour réaliser de nouveaux
progrès dans l'ensemble des
négociations aucun autre chapitre ne
sera provisoirement clôturé avant que
cette étape ne soit
franchie le Kosovo a progressé dans ses
travaux législatifs et adopté une
réforme électorale importante et le
Kosovo a continué s'aligner sur l'Union
européenne quand à la condamnation de
guerre d'agression menée par la Russie
contre l'Ukraine et adopté des mesures
restrictives la situation euh dans le
nord du Kosovo a été affecté par
plusieurs crises la dernière en en date
étant attaque contre la police kosovare
le 24
septembre nous notons que que bien qu'un
accord a été conclu en fin février et
mars cette année dans le cas de dialogue
sur un accord de normalisation et son
annexe ni le Kosovo ni le Serbie n'ont
commencé à mettre en œuvre leurs
obligations respectives qui sont
contraignants pour les partis et en font
partie de leur trajectoire
européen en raison de l'absence depuis
juin des mesures décisives pour apaiser
la situation l'Union Européen m en œuvre
des mesures à l'égard du Kosovo ce qui a
également une incidence sur la soutien
financière ces mesures sont
temporaires en fonction des décisions
prises pour apaaiser les tensions dans
le nord du Kosovo
enfin nous attendons le 1er janvier 2024
avec
intérêt attant date étant date à
laquelle la libération de régime de visa
pour la Kosovo entrera en
vigueur la Serbie a commencé à mettre en
œuvre les amendements constitutionnels
de 2022 vis visant à renforcer
l'indépendance des pouvoir judiciaire
elle a également adopté en octobre 2024
d'importantes lois sur les médias avant
la dissolution du
Parlement notre évaluation dans les deux
derniers rapport selon laquelle la
Serbie est rempli les critères
d'ouverture pour le pôle 3 compétitivité
et croissance inclusive reste valable la
Commission soutient l'ambition de la
Serbie d'ouvrir de nouveaux pôles
d'adhésion sur le fondement des de la
poursuite des progrès en matière de
réforme nous reconnaissons également la
bonne coopération en matière de
prévention de contournement des
sanctions mais la question essentielle
alignement sur la pesque y compris sur
les sanctions de l'encontre de la Russie
demeure
préoccupante passion maintenant passons
maintenant à la plan de croissant pour
les Balcans occidentaux et la nouvelle
facilité avec ce nouveau plan consiste
une nouvelle audicieuse approche vise
visant à l'accélérer une véritable
intégration c'est-à-dire une intégration
sur le terrain de nos de nos économies
de nos sociétés et à combler les fossé
qui qui nous
sépar cela portera des avantages
tangibles à chacun d'entre nous et en
amont de l'adosion les États-membres ont
demandé cette inégration accélérée et
progressive et ceci était également
notre projet présenté dans la nouvelle
méthodologie de
2020 l'objectif de ce plan est de
stimuler l'économie des Balcans
occidentaux au cours des prochaines
années prochaines années en finin de
combler le fossé socio-économique entre
l'Union et nos partenaires d'ici fin de
cette
décienne il repose sur quatre
piliers premièrement nous voulons
intégrer progressivement les balcons
occidentaux dans le marché unique de
l'Union européenne même avant l'adhésion
plein et un tiers à l'Union européenne
deuxièmement nous nous enforcerons euh
également de stimuler de l'intégration
économique dans la région des Balcans
occidentaux par intermédiaire du marché
régional commune euh commun fondé sur
les normes et les règles de l'Union
européenne
troisièmement le plan de croissance
aidera n nos partenaires de Balcans
occidentaux d'accélérer les réformes
fondamentales
y compris l'État de droit et la
démocratie elles sont nécessaires au
déploiement rapide de pan de croissance
lui-même attirant les investissements
privés favorisant en croissance
économique durable et résiduant la
pollution
enfin nous voulons augmenter
l'assistance financière afin d'aider nos
partenaires à accélérer les réformes au
moyen de
pour la réforme et la croissance de
Balcans occidentaux il
s'agite une d'une enveloppe de 6
milliard
d'euros comprend 2 milliards d'euros de
soutien non remboursable donc les
subventions et 4 milliards d'euros sous
forme de prê
favorable l'ajout de mécanisme pour la
croissance à l'aide relève de IPA 3 IAP
3 en
français offrira aux Balcans
occidentaux un
niveau niveau d'aide par habitant à peu
près identique à celle de politique de
cohésion dans l'Union
Européen l'objectif à plus long terme
est céder la région à expliquer
pleinment son potentiel en terme de
capacité de développement économique et
social par rapport raort aux États
membres de l'Union européenne d'ici
2030 les fonds seront débloqués de la
mise en œuvre des programmes de réforme
que nos partenaires de Balcans
occidentaux devraient
élaborer et qui devrait devront faire
l'objet d'un accord avec nous et être
mise en euœuvre au cours de période de
2024-2027
elles seront liées au réformes
socio-économique et fondamentaux en
résumé le plan de croissance créera les
conditions propice à l'adhésion de nos
partenaires régionaux à
l'Union permettez-moi de solliciter
votre soutien en particulier pour faire
en sorte que la proposition de règlement
établissant la facilité de croissant euh
soit
adopté avec une
efficacité accélérée
euh donc j'aimerais permetter ces longs
discours avec la
Turquie la Turquie est un pays candidat
comme monsieur le Président a aussi
indiqué et aussi j' joure un partenaire
essentiel pour l'Union européenne euh
conément aux décisions du Conseil
européen ces négociations d'adhésion
sont au point mort
depuis
2018 la Turquie continue s'igné de
l'Union
européenne le rapport conclut que le
pays n'a pas inversé cette tendance
négative consistance d'loigné d'avantage
de l'Union européenne et que nos
préoccupations persistent en ce qui
concerne le recul dans les domaines de
la démocratie de l'État de droit des
droits fondamentaux et des euh
indépendan de pouvoir
judiciaire le dialogue sur l'état droit
et les droits fondamentaux continue de
faire partie intégrante de relations
entre l'Union européenne et la Turquie
le refus de mettre en œuvre C un arrêt
de la Cour européenne de droits de
l'homme reste également un sujet de
préoccupation le relation bilatérale
entre la Grèce et la Turquie se sont
amilloré après le tremblement de terre
de février de la Turquie euh ne sait pas
s'engager dans des activités de forg non
autorisées en en mitterranée
orientale il est de plus haute
importance que la Turquie soutient
activement les négociations en vue d'un
règlement équitable global et viable de
la question chypriote dans la cadre de
nationsunis conformmément aux
résolutions pertinentes du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et confir bien sûr
avec les conditions
d'adhésion la coopération avec la
Turquie dans les domaines d'intérêt
commun c'est
poursuivi
dans dans les dans les domaines
essentiels tels que la lutte contre la
terrorisme l'économie l'énergie la
sécurité
alimentaire les migration et le
transport un environnement stable et sûr
en Méditerranée orientale et
dans notre intérêt et une insturation de
relation avec la Turquie fondée sur la
coopération et M Mutu fondé sur la
coopération et mutuellement
avantageuse relève de l'intérêt
stratégique de l'Union européenne comme
vous le
savez la Commission et le Haut
représentant
euh soumettront un rapport au Conseil
européen de ce mois-ci euh dans laquelle
nous exp exposerons d'autres options
pour développer cette
relation avec ces derniers mots
j'aimerais terminer le discours et je
suis prêt de répondre tous les
questions merci Monsieur le Commissaire
vous avez répondu partiellement aux
nombreuses questions que je vous ai je
vous ai posé mais vous avez ouvert aussi
je le constate d'autres d'autres
chantiers intéressants vous avez été
beaucoup plus locast que moi sur la
Turquie et je vous en remercie
considérant que
voilà la situation avance voire régresse
sur certains points notamment celui de
l'immigration euh dans notre commission
nous avons des rapporteurs spécialistes
dans dans matière d'élargissement et je
vais tout de suite leur donner la parole
donc il y a Didier Marie et Claude Kerne
dans l'ordre qu'ils choisissent
organisez-vous tous les deux je sais que
vous travaillez bien ensemble donc
Didier Marie qui qui va commencer et et
et je demande au collègues qui voudrait
s'inscrire de de bien vouloir bien
vouloir le faire merci président merci
Monsieur le Commissaire pour vos propos
liminires qui sont déjà fort
intéressants euh un certain nombre de
questions bien évidemment sont en
suspens on a bien compris euh que la la
Commission avait pris acte de la
situation géopolitique et de la
nécessité d'accélérer le processus
d'élargissement aux Balcans occidentaux
et euh à Raine à la Moldavie et
maintenant donc à la Georgie ce qui est
un élément nouveau sur lequel je vais
revenir dans un
instant bon nombre des états candidats
et vous l'avez rappelé on encore de très
importants progrès à faire en matière de
réforme pour respecter l'État de
droit qui à mes yeux doit être un
préalable à toute nouvelle intégration
et donc ma première question est de
savoir si la
commission sera et restera sur une ligne
stricte en matière de respect de l'État
de droit ou si elle sera prête à
certains aménagements au regard des
impératifs
géopolitiques d'autre part j'aurais une
question subsidiaire sur les questions
des migrations et et sur l'accord qui
vient d'être conclu entre l'Italie et
l'Albanie euh pour savoir si tout ceci
et bien conforme à l'état de droit tel
que nous le concevons
aujourd'hui entre nous d'autre part
pouvez-vous nous dire quelles évolutions
seraient à vos yeux nécessaires pour
s'assurer chemin faaisant et à terme du
respect de l'État de droit quand on
connaît aujourd'hui les limites de
l'application de l'article 7 du traité
sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne qui a montré toutes ses
limites à l'égard de la Pologne ou de la
hongri gr et donc qui pourrait poser des
difficultés pour la suite en cas
d'élargissement reste en suspens les
questions sur le fonctionnement d'une
Union européenne élargie à cet égard
serait-il possible que vous n donniez
votre sentiment sur le rapport des 12
experts franco-allemands qui ont été
mandatés par nos ministres respectifs
sur la question du vote à l'unanimité en
cas d'élargissement sur la
conditionnalité des aides au fur et à
mesure de
l'ouverture
des nouveaux chapitres euh et et la
question derrière c'est de savoir si on
peut faire ou non l'économie d'une
révision systémique de nos politiques et
une révision des traités sur la question
spécifique de la Géorgie
euh nous avons
été à la fois surpris et en même temps
satisfait des propositions de la
commission mais la situation politique
en Georgie est tout de même particulière
avec il y a encore très peu de temps une
tentative de destitution de la
présidente qui est pro-occidentale
pro-européenne et une intervention du
Premier ministre à l'issue de la
décision du Conseil extrêmement positive
mais totalement contraire à sa pratique
tant en matière de respect de l'État de
droit dans le pays que sur sa
ligne diplomatique très favorable à la
Russie donc j'aimerais que vous puissiez
nous vous détailler les éléments qui ont
fait changer la position de la
Commission à l'égard de la Georgie en en
si peu de temps de la même façon pour ce
qui concerne la Bosnie-Herzégovine euh
la formulation un peu ambigue qui a été
reprise par la commission laisse
entendre qu'en fait ils ne sont pas
prêts à rentrer dans le processus
d'élargissement pouvez-vous là aussi
nous dire à quel moment et sous quelles
conditions vous pensez que que les
négociations pourrai reprendre enfin
dernier
sujet le président du Conseil européen
Charles Michel a annoncer que
l'élargissement devait aboutir à
l'horizon 2030 que pensez-vous de cette
date je vous remercie
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Commissaire pour vos propos
liuminaire qui ont déjà apporté une
réponse à pas mal de questions euh je
voudrais compléter un peu ce que vient
de d'évoquer Didier Marie alors
l'Ukraine la Moldavie c'est une bonne
chose et personnellement je suis
particulièrement satisfait que la
Commission propose également au statut
de candidat la Géorgie pourquoi
personnellement parce que en tant
que membre de la de l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe je
suis rapporteur pour le monitoring sur
la Géorgie donc j'ai j'ai j'ai pu suivre
les les évolutions effectivement des des
réformes et les progrès qui ont été
faits dans ce pays parce que c'est vrai
s' reste encore beaucoup de choses
notamment en matière d'état de droit ce
pays a a fait pas mal de progrès Claude
je te coupe 2 minutes parce que il y a
il y a un bruit alors je sais pas il y a
un petit il y a un bruit désagréable sur
un des micros peut-être on est en train
de le chercher c'est une traduction
probablement et avec un micro ouvert
merci beaucoup
merci d'accord
donc euh oui il y a beaucoup de progrès
qui ont été réalisés et
euh une des questions était où en sont
les réformes dans les pays candidats
notamment en matière de d'État de droit
au respect des libertés publiques et je
pense surtout à la réorganisation du
système judiciaire et euh de la des
administrations publiques quand je parle
de réorganisation du système judiciaire
nous avions avec l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil d'Europe et la
la Commission de Venise émis un certain
nombre de recommandations envers la
Géorgie et notamment en disant c'est
bien beau de faire des réformettes
entre guillemets du système judiciaire
mais il faudrait peut-être penser à une
réforme globale de ce système
donc comment a été interprété cette
recommandation par la la
Commission européenne après en ce qui
concerne la
Bosnie-Herzégovine là vous vous avez en
ce qui concerne le plan de nouvelle
croissance pour les Balcans occidentaux
vous avez répondu en grande partie à ma
question je voudrais juste vous demander
est-ce que ce plan est destiné à
compenser l'absence de progrès
réellement tangibles en
bosnieherzégovine absence prise en
compte dans le paquet élargissement
publié hier justement sur la voie de
l'adhésion des pays de la région et PU
puis pour
terminer je voudrais insister sur une
question qu'avait abordé notre président
à savoir les conflits
gelés la Transnistrie le cas de la
Transnistrie le cas de l'abkazie de l'OC
du Sud Transnistrie c'est la Moldavie et
les deux autres la
Géorgie
comment l'Union européenne peut-elle
contribuer à la résolution de ces
conflits
parce
que nous avons nous au niveau du de la
PCE aucun moyen euh puisque en tant que
là aussi le président vient de vous le
souffler à l'oreille je suis président
de la sous-commission sur les conflits
concernant les les pays membres du
Conseil de l'Europe donc nous n'avons
pas de moyens aujourd'hui à même à les
faire dialoguer entre eux euh donc moi
moi j'aimerais bien savoir si l'Union
européenne a plus de moyens et que
surtout comment il compte les
utiliser c'est à vous Monsieur le
Commissaire puis après nous nous
passerons au aux questions Olivier cadi
peut se
pré merci
euh j'essaierai de vous répondre en
français mais il y a quelques
terminologies que je connais pas en
français donc excusez-moi
si si j'utilise ici ou là quelques mots
anglais aussiinprète mais B très bien
temporaire je fais un effort et on
arrivera monsieur merci donc le première
question sur soit nous prenons ligne
strictes euh ou géopolitique sur le
l'État de droit
euh notre commission je commence un peu
de de loin si vous me permettez donc
notre commission est le commission qui
qui s'appelle commission géopolitique
oui et c'est notre commission qui a mis
sur la table encore une fois l'adhésion
après une interruption euh de la
commission avant
nous et quand nous
avons quand nous avons fait notre
euh notre
planning je pourrais dire aussi notre
analyse de d'échec mais je reste plus
diplomatique donc quand nous avons fait
notre analyse au début de
mandat nous avons vu que
euh un des grands problèmes
euh politique autour de politique
élargissement était la crédibilité qui a
qui a été
affaibli pendant des années et cette cré
ilité a été affablie pas seulement euh
au Balcans mais aussi ici dans les États
membres
et une des sujets focaux dans cet
affaiblissement était le question des
réformes et dans les réformes bien sûr
l'État de droit et c'est à cause de cela
que quand nous avons mis sur la table de
conseil la nouvelle méthodologie euh
nous avons fait quand même une grande
changement par
euh par mettant le l'État de droit comme
point focal et comme une mesure absolue
de progrès euh dans dans dans la
politique d'adhésion et donc euh cette
méthodologie reste valide il y a aucun
aucun raison de le changer
euh pour euh l'État de droit euh il faut
toujours remplir les conditions si vous
lisez notre
rapport c'est c'est le cas et ça restera
le cas la
géopolitique la partie géopolitique
c'est plutôt comment on peut accélérer
euh l'adhésion par stimulant les
réformes et et pour cela nous
avons le growth plan pour cela nous
avons cette nouvelle nouvelle
facilité qui peuvent aussi contribuer de
faire accélérer les réformes liées au
l'État de
droit 2è question sur Italie et Albanie
cette cette coopération renforcée de
sécurité j'ai eu cette question hier
aussi au Parlement européen par un
député
italien à mon
avis
tous les accords
entre les les pays candidats et les
États-membres
sont de grande valeur qui euh contribu
un renforcement de notre sécurité
mutuelle et donc pour moi c'est c'est ça
l'angle d'où je regarde cet accord en ce
moment nous analysons euh cet accord euh
pour nous ce qui est très très
importante que ça doit contribuer au
sécurité européen mais je pense que
c'était la l'idée derrière derrière cet
accord et si l'accord euh est est
vraiment fait ça euh on peut même
soutenir
euh on peut même soutenir mais comme je
disais il faut il faut regarder euh
d'abord ce qui était conclu 3è question
euh c'était un peu difficile de de
comprendre mais j'ai écrit et si si
c'était pas le le sens de
question je reste à corriger donc euh
l'article 7 est c'est applicable peut
pourrait être appliqué sur les candidat
si je si je
traduire vos questions nous avons nous
avons établi cette conditionnalité
directe avec l'État de droit euh qui est
comparable euh à l'article 7 à mon avis
mais comme la situation d'être candidat
est complètement différente par rapport
d' État membre à mon avis euh nous avons
tout les nécessaire pour pour faire
euh une une intervention euh importante
si nous voyons qu'il y a une backsliding
c'était une une question aussi posée par
Monsieur le Président et et comme vous
avez vu nous avons vu une une une
backsliding par exemple en en en
Republica sska et nous avons euh
suspendu les fonds donc nous avons des
moyens et et nous utilisons les moyens
quand c'est nécessaire et
proportionnellement euh au pour pour
pour le pour le but ou pour le pour le
problème qui qui
s'merge le rapport de 12 expert comme
nous sommes dans une session publique
euh je dois
vraiment choisir mes mot attentivement
parce que première chose c'est pas mon
portef polio deuxièmement euh quand même
la commission
euh fait partie bien sûr le discours
mais quand même ce sont les questions
plutôt pour les
États-membres qui sont en
charge s'il y aura une réforme
institutionnelle euh donc j'aimerais
partager avec
vous mes vues
personnelles première chose c'est que il
faut à mon avis séparer le discours
autour de
l'adhésion et le discours autour de
réformes
institutionnelles je suis
convaincu et après après lisant le
rapport du service juridique aussi du du
conseil je suis encore renforcé dans
dans ces conviction que l'élargissement
est possible sans grande révolution
institutionnelle sans changement de
traité on peut y arriver avec tous les
moyens pour accueillir des nouveaux
États-membres donc pour nous euh il y a
il y a une une simultanéité mais pas une
conditionnalité entre les deux débats et
et mon avis à mon avis euh il faut euh
toujours observer cette parallélisme
plutôt que lier euh les deux choses
parce que euh ça pourrait
être un effet négatif pour tous les deux
débats euh si nous nous nous lisons
euh en ce qui concerne le qualified
majority voting euh qui est en question
courant
euh je travaille dans sur sur les sujet
l'Union Européen depuis
20 26 27 ans déjà donc j'ai commencé
comme comme juriste hongrois en
Hongrie à préparé la Hongrie et la
système juridique de la
Hongrie et après je travaillais des
années plus de 20 ans en Bruxelles euh
dans les couloirs de conseil commission
et tout ça et et quand nous avons
euh nous avons eu la première rencontre
au conseil avec les
États-membres grand c'était un grand
journée pour moi eu un grand événement
et une grand grand éducation aussi
euh il y en avait un diplômat franç un
diplomate français qui m'a expliqué un
peu les choses euh nous avons été assis
très proche l'un et l'autre et donc j'ai
j'ai appris beaucoup en parlant avec lui
et l'une des des grandes les grandes
leçons que que j'ai pris c'est que parce
que j'ai travaillé sur les sujets où euh
il y a que euh codécision et donc au
Conseil quif majority voting parce que
j'ai travaillé sur euh les les questions
économiques les questions de marché
unique et tout ça et il m'a disait que
oui oui oui quoi les fa majority voting
mais tout le monde doit euh et doit
avoir la possibilité de rentrer chez eux
avec une fierté même même si il était
voté
contre et c'est ça la question donc le
qualified majority voting
euh si c'est utilisé comme une
rétorsion
euh ce sera euh une ça sera une grand
échec de notre Union européenne si la le
qualified majority voting est
utilisé pour créer quand même une
politique consensuelle
avec tout le monde pourrait vivre même
s'ils sont pas d'accord avec la question
qui est qui est en vote ça va
fonctionner donc la Georgie la
destitution la présidente oui c'était
vraiment une une une proposition
politique qui était mal vu très très mal
vu par nous aussi nous avons fait le
point plusieurs fois mais maintenant
j'ai j'ai confiance que
[Musique]
euh cette partie de la politique en
Georgie est terminée
et et c'est à cause c'est à cause de
cela que nous avons regagné la confiance
euh dans dans le gouvernement que cette
sujet est maintenant terminé et à ne pas
revisiter
euh
et pourquoi nous avons proposé alors le
statut candidat parce que il y en avait
12 priorité euh posé par le Conseil
européen l'année passée
et dans cela nous avons vu que la
Georgie est capable de livrer et pas
seulement capable mais livrer plein de
choses nous avons une grande liste tout
ce qui a été
fait donc euh au niveau des conditions
qui a été posé par la Conseil européen
nous avons fait un grand progrès la 2ème
raison c'est que nous quand nous avons
fait notre analyse en février cette
année-ci de Aki report vous a vous
pouvez le voir que au niveau euh des de
comparaison euh de notre acquis et et la
Georgie euh nous avons trouver que par
exemple au niveau de fonctionnalité de
d'une une marché
compétitif les fondamental sont sont
Bones en Georgie donc il y a des des des
fondamentaux forts au JG au niveau de
comparaison de
l'acquis et la
trème
c'était bien sûr
que nous avons
vu depuis des années
des des dizaines des année la grande
soutien de peuple
Georgienne pour la cause
européenne parce que c'était la
Georgie qui au début de première
journée indépendance
regagné de de Russie Union soviétique le
choix était
et c'était suivi par tous les partis
politiques n'importe quel qui était en
gouvernance en opposition le choix était
toujours stable clair fort donc à mon
avis il faut
reconnaître cela et c'est à cause de
cela que maintenant nous mettons nous
faisons une je sais pas ça en français
libre de faith
euh pour la Georgie et nous mettant
alors la possibilité
euh sur la table de gagner euh statut
candidat mais c'est-à-dire que il faut
remplir les autres conditions et il faut
changer il faut changer quelques
quelques lignes distruptives que nous
avons vu que que nous avons vu donc il
faut renforcer le message vis-à-vis à
l'Union Européen il faut vraiment
diminuer encore
l'interférence desinformation et tout ça
dans le pays et donc c'est à cause de
cela que nous proposons le statut
candidat bosn
Herzegovina qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
alors ce nous avons proposé si si si je
si je analyse votre question bon euh
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
convaincus que cette construction
politique en
bosnieherzegovina pourrait livrer les
résultats importants nous avons vu déjà
qu'ils sont pas seulement capables mais
ils sont aussi en train de livrer des
réformes que nous avons pas vu pendant
des
années les réformes
difficiles eu qui prennent quand même
une une consensus politique interne dans
le pays de jamais vu donc à notre avis
le pays pourrait arriver
euh dans
une dans un niveau élevé critique après
quoi on peut proposer le l'ouverture
d'adhésion mais pour nous c'était très
très important de fait euh l'offre déjà
que il faut le continuer et nous sommes
prêts déjà nous avons préparé tout que
nous pouvons proposer cela d'ici
mars c'est ce que c'est ce que ça veut
dire que vous vous voyez notre dans
notre langage exotique de Bruxell euh
que nous reviendrons avec un un rapport
mais bien sûr le rapport sert seulement
si il y a de progrès
encore
donc
2030 ligne officielle de la commission
euh et que c'est pas la date qui compte
c'est la c'est la livraison des réformes
qui compte
et et ça reste toujours une une merit
based euh euh process donc là il n'y a
pas de
changement
mais si vous voulez vous pouvez aussi
liser un peu notre rapport et par
exemple si vous voyez euh le la parti
euh en ce qui concerne euh le growth
plan vous voyez quelques dates aussi
dedans 2027 Mo aussi 2030 ça paraisse un
peu ici ou là mais
comme je
disais c'est plutôt une
offre si ils sont prêtes nous serons
prêtes avec le growth plan nous mettons
en garde tous les possibilités d'y
arriver euh pour eux 27
30 comme il veut
mais les conditions restent le même et
il faut remplir tous les conditions
ge
Jud commission
recation il fait partie de
notre pas notre mais le devoir de de la
Georgie oui ils sont ils sont dedans ils
sont renforcés il compl
implentinglation
donc à mon avis ce que vous avez demandé
est dedans parce que pour
nous la Commission de
Venise le
standard vous avez vu avec Ukraine vous
avez vu avec la Moldavie vousvez avec
Georgie Albanie euh nous travaillons
très très étroitement avec eux parce que
pour nous c'est vraiment une qualité euh
que par exemple nous nous avons pas dans
Djir et c'est une c'est une organisation
qui est aussi acceptée comme authentique
par notre partenaire donc pour nous
euh d'y arriver avec tous les conditions
qui a été mis sur la table par la
Commission de Venise fait euh partie euh
des conditions euh de de de European
pass les conflits gelés ça c'est
peut-être c'est la plus facile question
de de la
journée euh
oui euh bien sûr euh c'est une stratégie
russe ou soviétique euh de près comment
oui voilà donc
donc nous avons nous avons beaucoup
d'exemples de cela la seule chose
l'Union européenne pourrait faire c'est
de soutenir nos partenaires avec une une
intégrité territoriale complet et et
nous pour nous c'est c'est une question
de fondamentaux
donc on va toujours soutenir tout de nos
partenaires qui est occupé ou il y a une
territori territoire désolu
autonome
euh on va toujours on va toujours
instituer la condition que il faut
restituer
territorialité intégral de tous les pays
donc pour nous c'est c'est vraiment fait
partir de de fondamentaux c'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire et c'est ce qu'on c'est
ce qu'on peut aussi utiliser dans notre
diplomatie externe
et c'est tout l'Union Européen pourrait
pourrait le faire à mon avis j'ai
répondu t les questions mais s'il y a
des plus on va passer aux questions de
la salle donc Olivier cadi et se prépare
Karine Daniel
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Commissaire oui en
fait ma question vient prolonger les
précédentes interventions moi je suis un
fervant partisan de non pas enfin de
l'adhésion de des pays des Balcans
occidentaux dans l'Union européenne et
pour moi c'est pas un élargissement
c'est plutôt une intégration puisqu'ils
sont effectivement sur sur le continent
dans un quart d'heure nous allons
recevoir enfin je vais recevoir Madame
vijanovic la membre bosno-serbe de la
présidence collégiale de bosn
Herzégovine et ça va être l'opportunité
pour moi de lui exprimer euh ma
difficultés face aux mesures
déstabilisatrices prises par Monsieur
dodic dans l'entité de republ serbska
euh de même que son discours
séessionniste nationaliste et prorusse
qui sont en fait inacceptables pour ceux
qui sont attachés à l'Union européenne
euh elle menace gravement aussi la
stabilité de la donc de ce pays de la
bosnieherzégovine et et donc son
unité et donc ma question ça serait de
vous demander quelle question
poseriez-vous à Madame
vijanovic dans une demi-heure pour
stimuler son action en faveur de
l'adhésion et pour convaincre le Conseil
d'ici mars
2024ine
Daniel oui merci tout d'abord j'aimerais
me réjouir du du signal positif qui est
donné à la Géorgie mais ma question va
plus va être plus centrée sur la
question de l'Ukraine avec
un un élan positif qui a été donné par
le malheur du du conflit en Ukraine à la
à la volonté d'adhésion qui sen sa'est
suivie et à et à la lumière qui a été
portée sur les discours et les propos du
président Zelenski quant à sa volonté de
de pouvoir contribuer au modèle européen
et évidemment on depuis la situation en
Ukraine ne s'est malheureusement pas
réglée elle a tendance à se prolonger de
manière trop
trop trop douloureuse pour t celles
toutes celles et toutes ceux qui en
Ukraine veulent rejoindre le projet
européen donc ma question c'est quels
sont les les prochaines étapes et
prochains éléments de dialogue avec
l'Ukraine dans un contexte qui reste
malheureusement celui d'un conflit
armé et puis toujours sur l'Ukraine vous
avez parlé et évoquer de la balance
qu'on doit tenir continuellement entre
les questions de marchés et d'ouverture
des marchés et de stabilisation des
marchés et de processus d'intégration
plus large et d'élargissement plus large
sur les questions d'État de droit sur
les questions de de réformes
structurelles j'aimerais savoir ce qu'il
en est sur les les marchés agricoles
ukrainiens et l'action de l'Europe
notamment sur les exportations parce
qu'on en a là aussi beaucoup parlé au au
début du du conflit mais qu'en est-il de
ce sujet actuellement
merci merci euh
donc c'est c'est pour moi de paraphraser
une question pour Madame
svanovic on parle beaucoup avec elle
donc donc je j'ai posé beaucoup de
questions mais je commence où où vous
avez commencé oui nous avons
vu
cette cette
tendance qui est qui est complètement
contraire de l'intérêt de pays qui est
complètement contraire de volonté de
peuple de la
bosnherzegovine euh et à notre avis euh
il faut bien bien
sûr toujours fait le point arrêter tout
cette tout c discours séparatiste
arrêter tout cette
discours déstabilisant euh mais il y a
une autre question qui est caché
derrière et c'est euh est-ce qu'on peut
regarder le pays
elle-même donc il faut pas pas
sacrifier le progrès de la pay pour un
homme c'est ça mon
point donc il faut pas
oublier que cet homme est pas égal avec
la
bosnherzegovine il faut jamais oublier
ça et c'est à cause de cela
que nous maintenant
poussons pour cette construction
politique qui fonctionne finalement
euh dans dans bosnzegovina euh pour
euh pour l'annexe le le prochaine étape
dans dans dans dans dans dans la chemin
européen donc à mon avis il faut séparer
et
euh en anglais ils
disent don't miss the woods for the
trees
euh donc euh ma question à Madame sera
qu'est-ce que vous faisz que la
bosnherzegovina va arriver en
mars avec une décision positive euh au
Conseil euh pour ouvrir les négociations
d'adhésion euh
Ukraine quelles sont les les prochaines
étapes maintenant euh notre proposition
euh est au conseil c'est pour le conseil
et donc pour les États-membres de de
faire adopté j'espère que les
États-membres euh suivront notre
recommandation donc euh en décembre
euh le Conseil euh affaires généraux
pourrait déjà euh adopter faire adopter
notre recommandation et après cela euh
le Conseil européen pourrait euh
indorse euh cette cette
recommandation dès que c'est fait euh
nous avons euh bougé donc euh avec la
préparation de negotiating framework euh
et euh préparer la décision pour
conclure euh le négoci framework avec
quoi euh l'étape de négociation pourrait
commencer par convenant le premier c ça
c'est de la technicalité à mon avis
c'est c'est c'est la question
institutionnelle mais au fond ici il y a
aussi les questions
euh de de de
de la question du du fond c'est-à-dire
euh des questions de
livrer encore les quatre priorités ou
conditions qui fait aussi partie de
notre notre proposition c'est-à-dire que
il y aura pas une étape prochaine euh
après la décision du Conseil européen
s'il n'y a pas une livraison sur tous
les sur tous les conditions qui a été
mis sur la table euh sur les marché
agricoes
euh à mon avis la solution pour le
marché agricole sera
euh les chemins qui a existé donc le
maire Nord pour faire les exports tout
cette tout
cette disturbance que nous voyons sur
notre marché sur le marché ukrainien est
à causé par la blocage de mer Noire euh
donc il faut le
travailler pour arriver avec une
solution pour le mer noir que euh le
transport pourrait recommencer et aussi
il faut travailler euh avec nos
États-membres pour les
pistes ferroviaires euh pour faire le
transit euh vers les marchés euh de de
de de marché traditionnel de de
l'Ukraine euh comme je suis responsable
aussi pour euh le voisinage du Sud
euh il y a une rupture euh énorme euh de
de supply
euh et dans notre marché il y a une
congestion donc il faut aider de de
livrer euh cette congestion
est est arrivé avec les les les le blé
et tout
ça comme c'est nécessaire pour nos nos
voisinages de Sud
absolument je je ne vois plus de
question dans la salle je vais je vais
vous en poser deux dernières avec à mon
avis une réponse courte dans dans les
deux cas vous avez cité le le gross plan
et avec affecté un chiffre qui est de 6
milliards je crois ou 6 milliards euh
nous avons fait un travail sur le le
cadre financier pluriannuel et en fait
on n' pas vu
apparaître le les éléments du gross plan
alors à quel titre est-ce que c'est dans
les les 80 milliards qui vont être
demandés en complément enfin voilà donc
ça c'est la la première question et puis
la deuxième vous êtes aussi en charge
des politiques de de de voisinage on a
vu une forme de flottement par rapport
au fond d'aide à la la Palestine dès
lors qu'il y a eu le le choc de de
l'acte terroriste de début octobre je je
voulais savoir o on en était dans dans
la réflexion puisque vous aviez pris une
position immédiate je pense dans sous le
coup de la probablement de la colère et
de l'effroid et et derrière on a vu une
rectification à la fois portée par par
certains chefs d'État et donc voilà je
voulais savoir où on en
était donc euh la
la révision de de
MFF contient 2 milliards d'euros qui est
le subvention élément euh donc si et
quand est adopté par le
Conseil nous aurons les fonds qui est
nécessair euh le la seule question qui
est à mon avis pas une grande question
c'est comment
créer l'autre partie le 4 milliards
d'euros de
crédit parce que nous quand même besoin
une une base financière euh avec quoi on
peut le garanti le l'élément de
garantie qui doit être quand même créé
mais là pour 4 milliards d'euros avec
une une multiplication de euh de de Neu
fois c'est ça le le chiffre en balcan
donc une demi mililliard d'euros ouais
on on le fait pour 50 milliards
quasiment à l'Ukraine sans sans réelle
garantie non plus ouis à mon avis à mon
avis non non il y a des garanties aussi
dans dans dans dans le casre de
l'Ukraine donc à mon avis euh si l'Union
Européen ne peut mettre sur la table
maintenant dans tous Cees contextees
géopolitique que 6 milliards d'euros
pour le
balcan nous pouvons vraiment clôturer
notre petite usine
ici donc euh oui euh sur le
fond palestinien
oui vous avez vu une réaction immédiate
et c'était une réaction immédiate pour
de pour deux raisons une euh c'est que
comme nous sommes européens euh avec une
histoire de
choix on peut pas être inégal quand il y
a une organisation
terroriste avec deux buts
une tuer les Juifs en masse et ils sont
arrivés de le faire et éradiquer Israël
comme tel qu'el donc avec notre histoire
on peut pas pas reste indifférent et
tout ce qui est passé
euh sur le 7 octobre a aussi évoqué des
questions
comment comment euh pourrait
Hamas grossir assz
fort parce que à partir de 2007 ils sont
complètement au contrôle de Gaza ils
étaient en charge de Gaza nous avons mis
beaucoup de nouveaux conditionnalités
quand j'ai arrivé comme commissaire en
2020 2021 avec qui nous avons déjà
arrivé une une une système qui esttre
beaucoup plus sûr que notre fond ne
euh ne n'est pas utilisé même
indirectement par les gens qui sont
associés avec ramasse ou autres
organisation terroristes nous avons des
conditions vraiment contraignants et
nous travaillons avec une très grande
très grande responsabilité euh sur cela
mais après le 7 octobre tout était
changé aussi sur le territoire
palestinien et maintenant il faut
regarder reg regarder que il y a pas de
bénéficiaires qui sont participés dans
ce qui est
passé donc nous avons une revue euh
maintenant euh on va terminer bientôt
euh vous allez le voir ce que nous avons
trouvons et nous aurons aussi les
suggestions à faire
euh comment continuer avec euh le le
soutien euh pour la palestinien euh
parce que bien sûr on veut euh continuer
mais on peut pas continuer comme c'était
donc euh c'est à cause de cela que j'ai
fait tous ces remarques et et oui après
il y en avait il y en avait beaucoup de
beaucoup de discours mais pour moi
c'était
impérative de parler
clairement clairement de premières
minute parce que c'est pas une nouvel
chapitre euh de de l'agression ou des
des des hostilités dans le dans dans le
MoyenOrient c'est c'est beaucoup plus
que ça ce que nous avons vu et après le
choix on peut pas rester indifférent
merci très bien écoutez merci merci
Monsieur le Commissaire vous avez été
assez précis dans vos dans vos dans vos
réponses et et franc et je vous en
remercie euh voilà je sais pas si vous
continuez un tour dans Paris
aujourd'hui je k d'orsé vous allez au k
d'orsé donc c'est c'est très bien ben
écoutez on vous souhaite une une bonne
journée une bonne continuation
sur votre votre mission grand merci